they're very upset they're very
concerned about this because nobody
involved with the series reached out to
anybody involved in the families on
Mondays dr. Phil for the first time ever
the families of Nicole Brown Simpson and
Ron Goldman will appear on the same show
voicing their anger over the new FX
miniseries the People vs OJ Simpson this
is a story about the trial and the
lawyers and I would lightly insensitive
though no not at all I mean this was one
of it was one of the this was a major
event in American history that only
happened because my brother was stabbed
to death and Nicole was nearly
decapitated we wouldn't be here if that
didn't happen the talk show host spoke
with et exclusively he says the crime
drama was done with respect it seems to
me that this is done in a very
responsible way and I think what they've
done is looked at it from the standpoint
of what went on inside the trial the
focus was not on the families the focus
was not on the victims and that doesn't
mean that they were that they were
disrespected that was just not the focus
of this particular miniseries everybody
pretty much saw my sister's body at the
bottom of the stairs covered with the
white sheet we all saw that they showed
Ron's body and dr. Phil when I saw that
I was like that is just the epitome of
disrespect dr. Phil says even 21 years
after the trial the families are still
in mourning they have never healed a lot
of these wounds it's still very raw
because they've never gotten to a point
of justice they've never gotten to a
point of satisfaction he's in jail but
he's never been held accountable for
what he did to their loved ones watch
dr. Phil's full interviews with Tonia
Brown and Fred and Kim Goldman on Monday
February 1st
you